direct cash payments will be available
to American citizens earning less than
99 thousand dollars per year expanded
unemployment benefits the average worker
who has lost his or her job will receive
100% of their salary for up to four full
months these are things that by the way
we have plenty more to go and but there
are things that nobody's ever had any
package like this then it's a big it's a
big amount of money a lot of money that
was President Trump from earlier today
touting the economic aid package that
passed the Senate last night 96 to 0 the
house is expected to pass a stimulus
bill tomorrow with bipartisan support
and a surprising twist Nancy Pelosi well
she's taking credit for it all oh he did
jujitsu on it that it went from a
corporate first proposal that the
Republicans put forth in the Senate to a
workers first Democratic workers first
legislation joining me now is House
Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy
congressman was Nancy Pelosi's 80th
birthday I believe today but did she
give herself a little gift there is that
is that is that what happened to make
this 2 trillion dollar bill better I
know it's her birthday but it does not
give her the right to lie 99% of this
bill was already decided on Sunday she
held the bill up and look what we just
found out today almost 3.3 million
Americans just lost their job last week
while she was holding this bill up for
why because she wanted to change
election law she wanted Planned
Parenthood to be funded she wanted the
green New Deal
if she wanted more money for sanctuary
cities that's what she was requesting
that's what we kept out of it this bill
is just about where it was she did get
24 million more dollars for the Kennedy
Center that's who that's her jujitsu
that's the only thing they're able to do
and think about what this bill does
provides funding for those who need it
by the income level we bribe money for
hospitals that are in crisis right now
but then we take the small business
where millions of Americans work for
and we provide funding we give them a
loan but you know the big part of it if
you pay your rent and you keep people
employed that is a grant from government
we're trying to keep people employed in
this nation go through this I'm hearing
from a lot of business owners people
have had to furlough nine hundred seven
hundred people in the last couple of
days and these people are heartbroken
and what their concern is is that we
need a date certain Bloomberg had a big
piece on this tonight that the date
certain is really the thing that is most
needed to inject a sense of we're
getting there's another side to this
we're gonna get on the other side and
it's not going to be a month it's going
to be date certain and they said if we
don't have that then two trillion
dollars is a drop in the bucket your to
your reaction to that well I think he's
watching this president this president
is looking and talking to his experts
but also realize and tells the American
public we will come back and business
will come back there may be spots of
America that could open up soon and
others would have to go through this
that's why in this bill it provides more
than two months to pay for your
employees to not lay them off keeping
them employed if you're a large employer
it helps you secure that loan but more
importantly gives you a tax credit where
the federal government is paying for
your employee about fifty percent of it
for next two months so yeah that date
certain is where this president is
working to to get America working again
and this bill allows you to stay
employed while that time gets goes
forward till we're all back strong again
what about the employees who lose their
health care what what I mean are there
gonna be more money for Obamacare
Medicaid I mean what are they going to
do well you know what the most important
is for them not to not to lose their job
and that's what this bill does if you
are a small business meaning if you have
fewer than 500 employees we are going to
provide you the money not alone but a
grant to pay your rent and pay your
employees you keep a hundred percent of
them you know what we pay a hundred
percent of that salary that allows for
the next two months that we get through
this just as you talked about date
certain we will get through this but
we'll keep you employed so you won't
worry about health and Shantou because
it's being paid yeah the businesses that
are struggling are the ones that are
more than 500 but
less than the behemoth tech companies
but congressman this was something said
today by LA mayor Garcetti who obviously
is himself bracing for the increases in
coronavirus he's making his own warning
giving his own warning to the rest of
America watch for anybody listening out
there this isn't just one of those
moments to say oh that's New York that's
LA I'm different from the smallest town
no matter where you are this is coming
to you everybody is the new whatever the
worst city is right now it's going to be
in Topeka it's gonna be in Atlanta it's
going to be in Louisville congressman do
you agree that what's happening in LA in
New York is gonna also come to smaller
town America medium sized cities in the
United States are they all the same when
it comes to covert 19 I don't think
they're exactly all the same and how we
react also makes a difference that
they're not mass transit we found
creates a bigger problem people washing
their hands more actually says people
distancing himself the things that we
have learned in the last month make us
safer and what's happening also on the
ground look at the therapies that are
being created look at what we're being
able from already when you're looking at
a trial when it comes to a vaccine it
took us two years to get to a clinical
trial after SARS we are already in a
clinical trial
so this president has fundamentally
shifted what's going on look at what
we're doing in testing in the last eight
days we have tested more than South
Korea tested in the last eight weeks by
the end of this week we'll be testing a
hundred thousand people in a day now dr.
Burke seemed to want to bring
everybody's fear level down because of
that faulty modeling that really got
everyone scared about the mortality rate
and the number of vents that would
ultimately probably be required as well
congressman thank you very much stay
safe out there great to see you